j'accueille stéphane guillon
bonsoir stéphane guillon pour ça va vite
presse de la semaine bonsoir c'est par
an nous écouterons
politique dans le figaro un reportage
sur la hongrie berceau de la famille
sarkozy si nicolas pères la
présidentielle on pourra alors envoyer
là-bas grâce à sa propre loi sur
l'immigration choisie
[Applaudissements]
lors de ses prestations télévisuelles
sarkozy porterait une oreillette et
alors ségolène aussi ce qui serait bien
sévir et le gars qui lui souffle des
conneries alors
[Applaudissements]
ségolène
avec moi tout le monde en prend au
sérieux pop droite gauche
sarkozy renonce à son projet sur le
suivi des malades mentaux dommage plus
d'espoir pour doc gynéco qui s'attaquent
d'ailleurs d'après le figaro le cannabis
perturbe le processus de mémorisation du
cerveau un encéphalogramme plat
n'empêche pas de temps en temps une
fulgurance dans son livre le dob déclare
le chômage est facile à résoudre il
suffit de trouver du travail
problèmes de mémoire encore dominique
voynet présente au procès de l'erika à
l'époque ministre de l'environnement
elle avait déclaré ce n'est pas une
catastrophe écologique non hein
c'était juste une grosse mouettes qui
avait choqué
le groupe total refusent d'indemniser
les victimes de la marée noire
dorénavant on ne viendra plus chez eux
par hazard
suscite de la soeur de letizia d'espagne
une certaine erika ne donnait pas le nom
d'un pétrolier un enfant ce
[Rires]
problème de mémoire toujours sur tf1 les
téléspectateurs ont applaudi jean marie
le pen après sa prestation à l'émission
j'ai une question à vous poser c'est un
nouveau chanteur le pen ce que moi je
croyais que c'était l'auteur du
calembour durafour crématoire
chicon
un espoir justement pour les mémoires
défaillantes un vaccin contre la maladie
d'alzheimer est à l'étude une première
tentative fut stoppée en 2001 après la
découverte de 18,4 d'encéphalite
heureusement les malades ne porte pas
plainte et se souviennent plus qu'on les
a vacciné
lors du meeting de ségolène à villepinte
françois hollande a compris la bam de
montebourg avec trois semaines de retard
chevènement lui l'a toujours pas
comprise là bas c'est le curare
politique internationale poutine propose
d'aider les saoudiens en matière
nucléaire tant mieux en radioactivité
les super balèze il a fait une démo sur
litvinenko en trois jours il était chaud
dans trois semaines il était mort
société
attention attention grève des gardiens
de musée quand ils travaillent ils sont
assis dans un coin sans bouger donc
grève très difficile à détecter
voyage moyennant un supplément une
compagnie d'avion propose à ses
passagers une classe sans enfant
destination la thaïlande la thaïlande
beaucoup de gens y vont pour se taper
des enfants mais il ne les supporte pas
pendant le
circulation delanoë at-il tout faux
titre le point non il ya des choses
formidables les pistes cyclabes cette
errance de vie 400 m les couloirs de bus
de 6 mètres de large quand le bus
s'emmerde il peut excéder et enfin ma
mesure préférée malheureusement il ya eu
une seule tentative la circulation
alternée ce jour là seuls les numéros
impairs pouvait rouler paris 75 tout le
monde a pu rouler
[Applaudissements]
chemise renault par s'installer en
angleterre pourvu qu'ils emmènent romane
serda avec lui
on termine par le meilleur bientôt une
expo dalida à paris les expos de chanter
en morts j'adore ça bientôt une expo
claude françois sponsorisé par edf est
également une expo mike brant où les
visiteurs pourront sauter à l'élastique
à la semaine prochaine merci beaucoup
merci celle que stéphane guillon et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu